in a Clash of Kings Daenerys was visited
by three figures while taking refuge at
the Forgotten city in the east bay's to
Laura xaro's on DOCSIS Pyat pree and
wait the masked a woman the pale man
with the blue lips replied in guttural
Dothraki
I am Pyat pree the great warlock the
bald man with the jewels in his nose
answered in the Valyrian of the Free
Cities I am xaro's on DOCSIS of the
thirteen a merchant prince of Qarth
the woman in the lagoon mask said in the
common tongue of the Seven Kingdoms
I am quake of the shadow we come seeking
dragons Xaro offered to host Daenerys at
his home while she was in Qarth he
promised her that she would have gardens
and slaves to tend her needs
Pyat pree had vowed to petition the
undying ones for audience with Daenerys
and gave her an ointment that he said
would allow her to see the spirits of
air quake however offered Daenerys only
a warning
beware of old they shall come day and
night to see the Wonder that has been
born again into the world and when they
see they shall lust for dragons are fire
made flesh and Fire is power later in a
Clash of Kings quite
earnest in there is to flee heart
warning her that if she stayed for much
longer she would not be permitted to
leave the ancient city danny's wrist
still tingled where quakes had touched
her where would you have me go she asked
to go north you must journey south to
reach the west you must go east to go
forward you must go back and to touch
the light you must pass beneath the
shadow a shy Dany thought she would have
me go to ash I will the yes i'ii give me
an army she demanded will there be gold
for me in ash i will it be ships what is
there in a shy that i will not find in
cart truth said the woman in the mask
and bowing she faded back into the crowd
we seek wait next in a Storm of Swords
and what first appears to be a dream
they sleep a woman said they all sleep
the voice was very close even dragons
must sleep she's standing over me who's
there
Dany peered into the darkness she
thought she could see a shadow the
faintest outline of the shape what do
you want of me remember to go north
you must go south to reach the west you
must go east to go forward you must go
back and to touch the light you must
pass beneath the shadow but quite makes
it clear that it was not a dream later
in a dance with dragons when she appears
yet again to the nearest atop a great
pyramid of marine a soft rustle made her
opened them again
she sat up with a soft splash Masson day
she called eerie G qui they sleep came
the answer a woman stood under the
persimmon tree clad in a hooded robe
that brushed the grass beneath the hood
her face seemed a hard and shiny she is
wearing a mask Danny knew a wooden mask
finished in red dark liqueur wait am I
dreaming she pinched her ear and winced
at the pain I dreamt of you on balerion
when we first came to ask the poor you
did not dream then or now what are you
doing here how did you get past my
guards
I came another way your gods never saw
me if I call out they will kill you they
will swear to you that I am NOT here are
you here no here means a nearest
Targaryen the glass candles are burning
soon comes the pale mare and after her
the others cracking and dark flame lion
Dan Griffin the Sun Sun and the mummer's
dragon trust none of them remember the
undying
beware the perfumes and
shall quate appears to Daenerys one
final time while saneras is lost within
the Dothraki sea she dreamed and all her
cares fell away from her and all her
pains as well and she seemed to float
upward into the sky she was flying once
again spinning laughing dancing as the
stars wheeled around her and whispered
secrets into her ear to go north you
must journey south to reach the west you
must go east to go forward you must go
back to touch the light you must pass
beneath the shadow Quaithe Dany cold
where are you quite then she saw her
mask is made of starlight remember who
you are
Daenerys the stars whispered in a
woman's voice the dragons know do you so
why is quite warning Daenerys the likely
option is that she must have some
interest in Daenerys as well being
wishing to guide her and keep her out of
harm's way
if quaithe had wanted denier he's dead
she has had plenty of opportunities to
do so instead she has gone out of her
way to warn Daenerys about possible
threats
it could be however that quake does not
have Daenerys his best interest in mind
there is a possibility that quake is
merely keeping Daenerys out of harm's
way for now so that she can extract
whatever she requires from Daenerys at a
time and place more suitable for her
could this place be shy Quaithe
introduces herself as quake of the
shadow
Daenerys takes this as meaning the
coitus from ash I the ancient black city
of dubious origin far within the corners
of the East but the shadow is a specific
place distinct from ash I up River past
the walls of ash isleye the mountains of
the mourn the heart of darkness where
ash comes howling through the cliffs
keeping the river in perpetual darkness
and at the heart of the shadow the
corpse city ash I is even referred to
many times throughout the series as a
shy by the shadow making a distinction
saying that ash I is beside the shadow
but not of the shadow itself
is quite telling Daenerys that she is
from a shy or from the Shadowlands and
if she is from the Shadowlands then who
is she what is she it is said that only
shadow binders who hide their face
behind mask dare travel up River into
the shadow for within the dead dark like
beasts old and terrible demons and worse
move amongst the shadows in the heart of
darkness and even shadow binders fear
what lies that's the guy the corpse city
a place in Lovecraftian lore wearing old
God sleeps if weight is from the shadow
then this could explain why she
possesses a glass candle it is said that
it was people from the shadow that first
taught the Valyrians to tame dragons
they taught them spells and sorcery as
well the only known glass candles in her
story came from Valyria
to the Citadel at Old Town a thousand
years before the doom of course if the
people from the shadow taught the
Valyrians to make glass candles they
would possess them as well I suggested
in my understanding the birth of dragons
video just over a year ago that there
seemed to be two forces pulling on
Daenerys through her dreams one seeking
to prevent the birth of dragons and the
other seeking to cause it wait is the
second force there to facilitate the new
age of the dragon
this makes Daenerys a storyline parallel
the rise of Valyria even more the people
from the shadow gave the Valyrians
dragons quite cause Daenerys dragons to
be born quite is from the shadow the
Valerians conquered all of old gifts and
formed an empire in a matter of decades
Daenerys has conquered a stupor marine
and young guy and has become one of the
most powerful political forces in the
East in the matter of months
both the Valyrians and Daenerys did
their conquering with the help of
dragons and the awe and fear they
inspire
perhaps quite is only masquerading as a
shadow binder perhaps she is something
more a representative of some greater
entity from deep within the shadow an
entity that has an interest in dragons
dragons are living fire made flesh not
dissimilar to the way that the others
are living ice this dichotomy supports
the idea that the Song of Ice and Fire
is a game a game with multiple moving
pieces spanning out over millennia first
the rise of the others and their fall
then the rise of the Dragons and their
fall now both players have reentered the
playing field evidence shows that the
others had been active for at least
decades before the opening of the game
of Thrones
Craster had been sacrificing his sons to
them and has many fully grown daughters
this would seem to indicate that the
others representing the site of ice have
had a head start the dragons are just
being born whilst the others have
already amassed a great army but who is
to say that the side of fire had not
already been trying to produce dragons
egg on the fifth grew increasingly
obsessed with dragons in his final years
no one knows why only that it ended in
the tragedy at summer Hall were seven
dragon eggs were brought to honor seven
gods but only held followed what caused
egg ons obsession perhaps the same thing
that caused the mad Kings of session or
even Daenerys his obsession
Danny's dragons are simply the first
success in a string of attempts to
facilitate the new age of dragons it is
quite possible that Aegon and the Mad
King were both visited in their dreams
the same way that Daenerys was before he
was known as the Mad King Aerys
Targaryen was described as quite
ambitious upon his coronation declaring
that he would be the greatest King in
the history of the Seven Kingdoms some
had even suggested that he would be
remembered as Aerys the wise or even
Aerys the great but it was not to be
through the years his paranoia and
obsession with via group
and in the end he would have burned all
of King's Landing to the ground
believing that he would rise up again
from the ashes as a dragon Denarius a
story would have likely ended in such
tragedy if not for the unlikely series
of events that led to the birth of her
dragons far too unlikely to be unguided
could Quaid have been present in the
time of Aries and Aegon as well and
simply failed or perhaps there was some
other agent of the shadow games follow
patterns recognizing these patterns
leads to an understanding of the rules
of the game the pawns in the world of
Ice and Fire
only glimpsed the world through wreaths
windows of time while the patterns only
reveal themselves over eons it would
then follow that only one who could
glimpse eons of time in one instance
could accurately see these patterns and
what would these patterns reveal to such
a person to see the grand strokes of
time is to realize the full impact of
actions and their consequences in a way
that one with a limited view could never
truly comprehend or understand whether
quite is the original agent or a more
adequate replacement is unknown what is
known however is that quite sees time in
ways that others do not
she knows truths that others have yet to
glimpse in that way she is similar to
Bloodraven although they play four
competing teams in the end which is
truly better fire or ice consumption or
preservation neither in itself is
necessarily good or evil a world of ice
is a frozen world unmoving unchanging a
world of fire is an ashen world chaotic
and furious but ever moving perhaps the
grand game is all that matters
the perpetual clashing of Ice and Fire
ever struggling maintaining balance